a pesar de que en el mundo continúan los
estragos de la pandemia como ya bien lo
hablábamos con marc y el doctor en
países como rusia las muertes aumentan
diariamente todavía existen personas que
se rehúsan a creer en la existencia del
cómic 19 la necesidad de vacunarse
contra esta enfermedad es que a veces
son personas públicas influyentes
quienes más levantan la polémica por su
actitud frente a la actual crisis
sanitaria los casos más polémicos lo
protagonizan los deportistas que juegan
en los equipos de baloncesto o fútbol ya
que están en contacto físico y directo
con otras personas esto evidentemente
aumenta el riesgo de los contagios de
kobe 19 para ello saludo en este momento
a nuestro segundo invitado al es a
norberto de bach cardiólogo y médico
deportólogo médico del club atlético
atlanta en argentina doctores de bach
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 le pregunto
la primera pregunta los efectos que
tiene la vacuna en el cuerpo de los
deportistas de alto rendimiento los
afecta realmente
bueno gusto estar con ustedes en primer
lugar el día que las vacunas no está
demostrado todavía que tenga un efecto
negativo en el rendimiento deportivo y
que lo mejor es micro deteriores el
rendimiento deportivo esto
indudablemente todos los años todos los
veces a unas semanas estamos aprendiendo
cosas nuevas del cobi y de las vacunas
por lo tanto va a haber que hacer un
estudio a largo plazo para ir sabiendo
las consecuencias que pueden tener en
general las vacunas y también las
consecuencias a nivel deportivo si las
hubiera ahora doctor también hablamos
digamos de los atletas de alto
rendimiento estas vacunas pueden
registrar en algún momento un doping
positivo esta pudiera hacer digamos para
entender un poco el lado de los atletas
y los deportistas una razón por las que
ellos no quieren vacunarse contra el
kobe 19
no es el motivo de la
agencia mundial antidopaje en ningún
momento tiene
previsto poner las vacunas como esté
doping así que ese no es una simple
excusa hay otros motivos hay personas
que no están de acuerdo con la vacuna
los cuales hay que respetar pero bueno
tienen otro criterio otro pensamiento
con respecto a las consecuencias que
puede tener a futuro con las vacunas
bueno esos son son conceptos que hay que
respetar pero que este por el momento
con respecto al doping no no hay nada
concreto de que sea positivo en el
doping acá en este caso digamos autor
entonces que esta reticencia a la vacuna
y el miedo digamos a esta vacuna contra
cohetes y 9 es algo más ideológico que
científico
claro es decir las evidencias
científicas son las que tienen valor las
personas que no reconocen las evidencias
científicas
entonces es bueno acá como bien lo decía
el colega anteriormente hay centros como
la fd como una versión mundial de la
salud bueno y cada uno cada país tiene
su organización que va a determinar si
está la vacuna en condiciones de ser
aplicadas entonces yo pienso que hay
muchos argumentos científicos que lo
avalan pero bueno hay personas que en el
mundo no
están de acuerdo con esta vacuna y a
veces con algunas trabas curas que no
sean que no sean obligatorias porque
aquellas vacunas que son obligatorias
principalmente en edad escolar
bueno ahí sí es obligatorio porque si no
no van a no van a poder ingresar una
escuela pero en este caso que todavía no
es obligatorio diríamos
a nivel internacional
bueno hay que respetar estas personas
pero bueno científicamente está
demostrado que es efectiva doctor y lo
que también es cierto usted como
cardiólogo ahí se han presentado casos
de cardiopatías por estas vacunas que
sabemos sobre esto y cómo puede afectar
el rendimiento pues la salud del corazón
de estos atletas de alto rendimiento es
por ejemplo un futbolista un maratonista
si esto se ha demostrado que los mismos
receptores que tiene el pulmón no tiene
el corazón así tenemos nosotros que
cuando teníamos afecciones a nivel
respiratoria generalmente eran las
neuropatías bilaterales pero esos mismos
receptores estar en el corazón entonces
tienen afección cardíaca también al
comienzo de la pandemia las cifras eran
muy altas lo que había poca cantidad de
grupos estudiados de afecciones
cardíacas moskowitz pero odio durante el
transcurso de la enfermedad pero hoy en
día hay estudios mucho más de estudio de
2500 de 1500 como que es importante la
muestra y eso ha demostrado que produce
una afección cardíaca se calcula en los
deportistas lo que más vemos volvemos en
argentina que hemos visto no demasiado
que lo que se ven en la miocarditis que
la inflamación del músculo miocárdico
que esto tiene como consecuencia la
producción de arritmia cardiaca
insuficiencia cardíaca e inclusive la
muerte ya que la miocarditis es una de
las causas de muerte en el deporte si
bien hoy se está viendo con más
frecuencia un poco más frecuente por
esta pandemia
antes el virus influencia de la gripe el
cosac y otros virus como el de la
mononucleosis también producían
afecciones cardíacas sus cuadros virales
que afectan el corazón pero por suerte
se ha calculado ahora que entre entre
ellos diría que entre uno y medio y dos
por ciento son la posibilidad de tener
una miocardiopatía más que nada una
miocarditis esta inflamación que
comentaba yo del corazón pero también
puede haber otros casos como
pericarditis que es la inflamación de la
membrana que cubre el corazón y a veces
casos de arritmia y en cuadros de muerte
súbita que se ha descrito en pacientes
internados